kurze info ich schon das video am
flugzeug deswegen werde ich das nicht so
krass bearbeiten aber trotzdem viel spaß
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem neuen video war
ich hab mir gedacht ihr euch mal ein
neues video
ja das ist ja das ist der grund lag wie
durch außerdem spaß ich bin ein spaß das
ist das ist auch der grund ja ziemlich
viele gründe heute mein kumpel max hat
mir heute geschrieben jolokia ich hab da
so läuft wie auf einem kanal gebracht
das heißt murphy bot macht das auch mal
das erste mal für den kanal geeignet ich
habe gerade alles klar
ihr seht schon hier wir sind in skype
drin ich bin in einem chat mit dem
murphy bot das ist er mit diesem
hübschen profilbild hier das ist so ein
kleiner roboter ich habe den schon super
nachrichten geschrieben wie
beispielsweise tag beantwortet doch alt
da will ich vom portokasse spitzer mit
schauern oder damit sie was aus der
minister will es schaffen
und da kommt jetzt gerade halt noch
keine antwort allerdings ist es ein wort
mit dem man schreiben und interagieren
kann der es dauerhaft online und ich
kann ihm sachen schreiben wie
beispielsweise what if we work max oder
so dann wird er sagen wie ich aussehen
würde wenn ich auf max körper wäre und
wir gucken einfach mal was der so
schreibt jemand etwas einfaches und zwar
bot obama wird bei putin so jetzt
schauen wir mal das habe ich jetzt die
frage geschrieben und jetzt macht weight
ein
landis question is taking the white
heftige back to you later und dass man
vielleicht auch funktionieren oder jetzt
mal einfach diese standard frage von
hier oben und zwar what if abraham
lincoln had a very long die acht mal das
ist ja zu komisch als zitat hier raus
gekommen
februar im lincoln had a very long wird
so das hab ich mir jetzt beschrieben und
jetzt musste er murphy bot so sieht also
abraham lincoln mit einem ziemlich
langen bart aus und was ist wenn ich
jetzt schreibe what if konkreter hätte
very long bild jetzt mal abwarten als
wenn als wenn ich jetzt jetzt ich what
if konkreter wurde emma watson so emma
watson ist ja die von harry potter die
hermine gespielt hat die wollte ich
einen schon normal sein
habt ihr euch eigentlich früher auch in
die verliebt aber ich war mal voll
verknallt in die 3
irgendwie hat der murphy bots noch nicht
so raus mit nachdenken und schnell sein
weil es kommt noch immer keine antwort
auf diese frage
das ist konkreter als emma watson alter
ok dann lasst tatsächlich echt an meiner
seite' grammatik ich voll spaß soll ich
mich vielleicht mal vergaben gehen ich
hab mir gestern schon eine schaufel
bestellt alles klar
es lag alles klar klar ob obama was
putin das wird mich auch mal
interessieren
das haben wir am anfang so als standard
frage genommen und jetzt kommt obama ist
gut den ich mag ich bin übermannt und
ich bin grad auch pudding weil mit dem
kart fahren dann einen ganzen fanboys
und so möchten jetzt wahrscheinlich in
bezug auf swiss award of crime craft
dotcom crash da ist geht ein und jetzt
zeigt eine mischung aus max und mir
quasi so in einer person an und ich bin
nicht ich will das gar nicht sehen
eigentlich max denn wenn du wirst
wahrscheinlich dieses video aussehen
erst mal schöne grüße an dich denke dass
eingeschaltet hat guckt immer die
mischung aus uns beiden hier an wir sind
tatsächlich wir sehen sehr so aus als
wären wir tatsächlich sehr sehr
ja ich weiß nicht warum mir wurde vor
allem nach volker wiebels aufgeschrieben
ich würde irgendwie aussehen wie ksv wie
marcel finde ich eigentlich gar nicht
findet er wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
aber ich habe es einfach mal einige
motiv konkret krieg und es kam dass hier
raus wir sind also die ähnlichkeit ist
verblüffend ich habe vorhin eingegeben
wurden kräfte wars krieg ich habe jetzt
mal eingegeben jfks froscon crafter und
da kommt jetzt der cdu okay
immer standard weise die gleichen
bildern bei what if krankhafter was
konkret kann man auch dieses komische
bild von maxi mir raus und wenn ich
jetzt eingegeben habe jfk swisscom
crafter commodities komische bild ich
verstehe bis jetzt auch ich gehe jetzt
mal ein what if crafter rostowski mail
also wenn ich weiblich wäre ich weiß
nicht ob das ist doch egal what if the
boss babys beautycase das wird mich
wirklich mal interessieren weil dass wir
diese beiden beauty queens die sich
gegeneinander ketsch in den kopf brennt
ag oder baby oder wer auch immer von
seiten des kroatischen dem welt was max
auch schon in seinem video gemacht hat
war what if kong crafter russin alpaca
ich habe zwar schon mal max gesehen aber
ich möchte euch auch noch mal zeigen
weil es einfach ultra witzig aussieht
also man kann auch irgendwelche tiere
dar einpacken das heißt ort das ist doch
jetzt nicht wahr ich glaube max hat das
ganze mit k geschrieben das alpaka das
sage ich auch noch mal aber ich hab's
mit c geschrieben deswegen sieht das
ganze so aus wie wenn ich also das sind
zwei alpakas und ich bin einfach in der
mitte
das hat auf jeden fall super
funktioniert also wenn ich ein geber
what if kong crafter was ein alpaka mit
cadan sind jetzt schreibt er jetzt
wieder diese kommission mit den smileys
jetzt kommt dieses bild und man denkt
sich jetzt mal so im ersten moment
zuhörers luca da ist luca ja direkt in
der schnauze von nimmt man warum soll
ich die scheiße hier prost auf einen
schönen mangosaft ihr motiv kongress
alien und wir haben als bild dieses dk
was haut denn diese website raus alter
ohne spaß ich habe gesagt clever bot
okay da habe ich schon ultra viele
videos mit gemacht aber ich glaube mit
dem murphy bot kann man noch viel mehr
schwarze machen an dieser stelle danke
dann dich max schaut euch auf jeden fall
max video an der stelle an wollt ihr
vielleicht auch guck mal hier weil sie
an abstiegskampf pur
richtig brenzlig noch mal kurz einkaufen
könnte village.de
wollt ihr dass ich mehr murphy bot
hochladen als ich mein ohne spaß es
macht so viel fanden weil es gibt ich
komme jetzt mal gerade auch nicht auf
die ganzen ideen aber locker wenn ich
euch sage schreibt ihr mal in die
kommentare was ich den murphy bord
fragen soll also schaltete die
kommentare so was wie luca fragt den
markt nochmal what if
krankhafter watched at oder das machen
wir doch mal eben kurz ja wer mag schon
so oft genommen haben in diesem video
habe ich jetzt einfach mal genommen what
if the others dead an dieser stelle
nichts an dicht nichts gegen nicht gegen
dich 10 6 1 heraus sei jetzt ein
bisschen abgewartet und der map report
meldet sich nicht auf diese frage das
heißt ich glaube der brauch wirklich
immer so einen normen bzw eine person
wars und dann noch eine andere person
oder eine person und dann hätte very
long bild oder so und dann etwas kann
man daneben bot fdj the devil also ich
weiss nicht als devil teufel ich bin
okay okay es kommt es kommt es kommt und
den als toll doch gerade an dieser
stelle wäre nicht auch das heutige video
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr euch
denken bord ist echt nice war damit kann
man so viel spaß abdecken bitte drücken
ich habe und roboter von noch mehr hoch
zu laden wenn ihr da auch bock drauf
haben dann schreibt mir die kommentare
luca frag ihn motto rettet mich wir
sehen uns einem anderen video wieder hat
ein chat